j'ai trop linéaire mais s'il vous plaît
commencé mais pas la faire tourner ou
quoi la photo elle l'a pas fait exprès
j'ai trop les deux bons 13 12
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle a fait une faute au regard des noms
alors ah ça c'est ma règle alors voilà
c'est vrai en fait derrière si vous
regardez bien derrière la personne est
en fait nous savons qu'elle est un peu
cette nuit habite aidez moi parce que je
ne sais pas de quoi
[Applaudissements]
l'amour et qu'il s'en veut énormément
franchement à culpabiliser parce que
c'est sa fille et qu'elle voit la cccc
dur pourrait elle a fait cette photo
elle a posté dans la précipitation faut
dire aussi qu'elle était dans un moment
de deuil aparté après fin mai il y avait
un enterrement etc n'étaient pas très
bien à la vanille alors but fait pas
très jeune comme moi j'ai pas de sa
maman a tort en fait à l'apa elle est
sortie en vitesse et elle a pas réfléchi
à la fin n'a pas regardé la pas vérifiée
elle a posté sa vie d'abord fait il est
vrai qu'un général maeva gainey entend
pas dire qu'elle soit tout le temps très
amis et donc oui mais
moi je vous explique moi après ça quand
ça s'est passé - my val m'a appelé tout
de suite elle était en crise elle hurle
et de tristesse et toute la faute aux
attendes la photo a tourné deux partout
avant et en fait quand on s'expose et
cons et qu'on a envie de montrer une
partie c'est une chose mais quand
les vagues et moi
je suis d'accord avec vous mais en fait
il ya le fait de diffuser plutôt bien de
montrer en fait c'est pas la même chose
outre la mère ce qu'elle veut de vernon
scalpel des photos elle avait passé j'ai
trop linéaire mais s'il vous plaît comme
on s'aimait pas à la faire tourner ou
quoi la photo et l'a pas fait exprès
j'ai trouvé de bons très dur
c'est une vraie dame
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
attendez vous aurez pas ça parce que
précédemment
à droite wade petit chien a envie d'être
et à la droite
et à te le dire ça n'a le droit légal et
je réagis et comme c'est comme ça des
cov avec les mac and staff c'est vrai
que on comprend la tristesse qui est la
sienne ah non mais je crois qu'ils
s'expriment ça fait rigoler et là c'est
vrai que la halle est en larmes c'est
pas non plus la mort du petit cheval
mais bref tant que danse achats d'or
j'adore mais bon ça arrive c'est une
gaffe de ckac va très bien les passions
des avantages aux puces à la photo elle
et on la voit elle est loin c'est le
flou oui et dire arrêtez de faire
tourner la photo malheureusement elle
sait très bien que c'est impossible qu'à
partir du moment où s'est posté le monde
a capturé
elle n'a pas demandé à ce que cette
photo est sa pub c'est vrai oui savourer
sans voir que l'univers céline fargeot
là c'est l'univers qui pose problème
pour moi c'est pas vous imaginer la même
histoire en angleterre le prince charles
il ya ça me
l'univers est différent la culture est
différent la vue on a vu des petits
laharie paris on avait tenu un des
jarrets
traversé une période noire
j'avais dit en voyez vous une photo de
votre pénis comme ça souvent c'est un
honneur de mon pays ni non j'ai mis des
photos de moi nue elle fallait envoyer
des photos de moi oui voilà à la
mauvaise personne non
cette gêne et edge 200 kg vient pas de
doute
parce que des fois
ouais moi y'a il ya quelques années mais
je dis pas quand parce que voilà
quelques années j'ai fait un live sur
instagram pour parler voilà et en fait
c'était en été et c'était pas un
confinement même où on est un peu en
pyjama ou en fait pas trop gabon en
l'occurrence j'étais en robe et c'est
vrai que j'avais parmi tout bêtement
parce qu'en fait il faisait chaud et
tout machin est donc je fais mon live
j'étais sur mon lit et tout j'ai fait
mon live je les poster et ensuite mon
meilleur ami il m'a envoyé une capture
d'écran il me dit c'est incroyable on
dirait vraiment et à rien en dessous pas
j'avais des jambes et je regarde ça et
je fais un gd même pas au courant je
regardais et du coup j'ai supprimé mon
live enfin nantes inquiète c'est
vraiment une erreur d'image c'est trop
drôle et tout donc personne n'a jamais
rien su lui l'a vu peut-être que
d'autres personnes sont posé la question
et ça moi je le jure
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il n'est pas nécessaire de se limiter
dans tel un requin pour retrouver le
sourire parfait non ce procédé
d'ailleurs très dangereux et vous
pourriez très vite perdre toutes vos
dents
ce soir le docteur never sonne l'alerté
témoignant des pmp
[Musique]
bonsoir dr never say quoi vraiment
serait trouverez non je te veulent mais
le prénom c'est j'avais me voilà et je
donne pas mon jeu n'est pas bon non ah
ouais c'est vrai je reste anonyme je
répète je fais pas ça pour faire de la
pub voilà c'est juste pour faire de la
prévention sur les réseaux tout ça donc
vous faites un livre quand dr never oui
il ya pas marqué mais meurt
jamais
il ya des gens qui vont comme ça à
l'étranger pour des facettes nation le
problème c'est qu'ils repartent avec
autre chose que des facettes ils
repartent avec des couronnes et en fait
une couronne nécessite vraiment de
beaucoup taille et la dent et dans le
cas où les dents sont saines c'est de la
mutilation d'organes vivants parce qu'un
résident sont des organes d'avancé alors
si lauriane dentaire c'est déjà le nez
plein de conseils parce que c'est vrai
qu'il ya des trucs de fou qui se passe
ils
n'ont ce qu'on voit là en fait c'est
cetc des préparations pour des couronnes
en fait pour pouvoir poser une facette
c'est une préparation vraiment
pelliculaire ça veut dire que on enlève
quasiment rien de la dent il ya même des
facettes sans préparation on n'a pas
besoin de faire tout ça parce qu'en
france on fait bazas en france il ya il
ya une règle d'or c'est la préservation
titulaire césar on préserve les tissus
dentaires l'émail la dentine au maximum
oui donc voilà c'est on essaye de
conserver au maximum parce que il faut
pouvoir ré intervenir sur ses dents là
en fait c'est dans la admettant qu'elles
soient conservées de vente si un jour on
doit réintervenir sur ses dents on doit
les tuer là c'est tellement proche d'une
ère que le jour on doit à réintervenir
là dessus on tue la dent donc ça veut
dire que là ils ont ils sont gen les
patients qui sont là y en a qui ont 19
ans 1 dans quinze ans ouais oui c'est
des patients gêne dans 15 ans si on doit
refaire une intervention voilà bah c'est
on tue toutes les danses est pas qu
il aura des vraies dents dévitalisées
mais avec des prothèses dessus mais là
l'étape d'après oui ça sera peut-être
l'extraction et cinq conseils pour avoir
dit don au top ce que c'est important un
beau sourire c'est avant tout un sourire
qui en bonne santé c'était hyper hyper
important un sourire naturel assuré en
bonne santé c'est hyper-important
choisie laisse pour savoir si on a une
bonne ou une mauvaise haleine en fait on
va tester notre haine comme s'ils ont
testé un parfum au caire est ainsi donc
comme ils font dans les parfumeries
alors mais sur le poignet tu dois te
lécher les babines exactement lécher le
poignet l'intérieur ici du poignet si
vous laissez sécher et après
alors c'est horrible
l'aca est quoi ouf
je suis pourri un peu droit
certains parfois en anglais c'est le
pape un fruit pourri si on souffre d
little il faut se brosser si la langue
avec ingrate lang a déjà vu ça voilà
voilà donc il faut qu'ils veulent faire
avec la brosse à dents
avec ce cas derrière la tête de la
brosse et l'espèce des petites surfaces
ce siliconée faut pas le faire avec la
brosse à dents parce que les poils de la
brosse à dents peuvent faire des micro
irritations et fidélisation sur la
langue et apprendre la langue râpeuse
mais c'est surtout que les bactéries
responsables est mauvaise et ne peuvent
se loger dans ces petites irritations et
ça peut être pire mais non rappeuse
mathieu c'est pas bon
il faut bien s'hydrater aussi exactement
bien s'hydrater c'est très important à
aller voir son dentiste au moins une
fois par an parce que on a beau avoir
une bonne hygiène 6 à décarie des mâts d
atteindre parodontale sur des maladies
des gencives tout ça et faire attention
à ce qu'on mange il ya
toujours des aliments les connais live
voilà certaines dé tunis l'alcool tout
ça christian mauvais le paprika ouais
bah voilà tout ça vous fera danser
[Musique]
couture même les fringues sont
elles sont sales de téléphone date de
juin en lice et des gens qui rient au
dix huitième degré dans la salle au lieu
d'encourager quelqu'un qui se sort de la
merde oh la la bd questionner leurs
qualités cette critique et les gens qui
ont envie de se faire une situation ou
sauvé au machin et se battent des gens
un peu comme ce petit gros là
ça les instruit
mais attends tu fais donc alors si tu
revois ces propos a déjà je suis désolé
d'avoir gâché son week-end j'ai entendu
le début de l'émission ouais c'est vrai
tu as perdu au paddle en plus oui
c'est pas voulu voilà on ne prévient pas
que je dis ce que je pense c'était mon
rêve voilà c'est tu peux dire tout ce
que tu veux sur les gens tu peux dire
qu'il n'a pas de carrière qu'il est nul
mais continue de remplir par mtv un
petit gros
c'est pas possible alors
carrefour on veut des rites et grands
aux yeux bleus non c'était un petit gros
avec moustache c'est une déception
[Applaudissements]
tu as été blessés franchement [ __ ]
mais je me suis si je me suis fait
[ __ ] je me suis fait
sur le mot sale pour moi ce qui est sale
c'est pas toi c'est pas ta peau c'est
pas tes mettons aline jamais pris comme
ça donc ce que moi j'appelle des choses
sales c'est quand par exemple but à
l'heure tu nies [ __ ] trois fois c'est
matin dans des endroits pas chier
alors s'est plaint tout laissé tomber
hier soir ses programmes à la jaloussée
pas de changement je dois j'ai mon
pauvre arrête tu peux pas quoi faire le
train vide
[Rires]
séparé
je ne ferai pas quatre semaines tu le
ferais comme les varna au palace monde
et pièces devenues
très dures
[Applaudissements]
le kanak res chanac res connu pour ses
participations dans plusieurs télé
réalité comme les marseillais où les
anges elle avait fait parler d'elle le
mois dernier en annonçant les sur les
réseaux sociaux qu'elle attendait des
jumeaux mais l'un des deux bébés avec 98
pour sanction de probabilités d'être
atteint de trisomie 21 on dirait que
vous allez voir la vidéo qui fait parler
et qui fait polémique
direction du coup une salle
d'accouchement on va me faire comme une
péridurale mais c'est pas vraiment ça
pour une anesthésie c'est très dur pour
tous les deux mais heureusement qu'on
est ensemble c'est vraiment pas facile
et ensuite on nous laisse donc socke ou
dans une salle même salle pour pouvoir
bien pleurer
vider notre sac pendant à peu près deux
heures alors juste pour indication un
enfant ressemble des choses à partir de
18 semaines puisque c'est à partir de ce
moment qu'il a des terminaisons
nerveuses je suis enceinte de quinze
semaines du coup le bébé n'a rien senti
cet or nettoyer alors gilles verdez
saoudien non ça ne me dérange pas je
suis de leur côté d'accor qui revit ils
vivent un drame à partir du moment où
ils ont exposé la joie d'attendre des
enfants il centre guillemets obligé par
rapport aux gens qui les suivent et je
trouve ça très honnête de leur part même
si c'est douloureux d'exposer la suite
dramatique triste et cette désespérante
qui ne doivent rien à personne là ils
ont eu envie ils ont eu besoin de
raconter une histoire intime personnelle
extrêmement douloureuse qui sommes-nous
pour les juger à ce moment là de leur
histoire de couple là il parle de
quelque chose qui peut toucher au coeur
aussi des jeunes gens qui les regardent
qui peuvent éventuellement surtout dans
ces situations là
moi je la connais pas du tout mais je
sais que enfin je la suis depuis
longtemps ça fait longtemps qu'elle est
dans le milieu et je pense qu'elle a
assez de follower pour pas se servir de
ça pour en faire du business à partir
non une personne peut se rattacher à
quelqu'un qui vit la même chose comme
les forums qui existe depuis des années
sur internet moi je pense que c'est
important qu'elle le montre et c'est pas
comme ça qu'elle va gagner de l'argent
donc je pense que c'est plus pour aider
les personnes que pour faire du business
qu'elle fait là richard cyril vous
parler du jeu d influence sur moi je
pense que ce jeu il a des limites moi ce
qui me gêne déjà c'est la mise en scène
c'est pas comme une télé réalité
classique où ils sont suivis par des
caméras qui filment leur quotidien la
cee qui se filment eux mêmes et qui met
en scène ça en se filmant eux mêmes en
mettant des musiques émotion en les
publiant voulant faire des vues donc
déjà cette envie de faire du buzz entre
guillemets autour de ça elle me gêne
ensuite la décision qu'ils ont prise
elle est extrêmement intime et ça les
regarde et je trouve que c'est un peu
maladroite de médiatiser un moment aussi
intimé compliqué parce qu'il ya plein de
gens qui ont des enfants qui sont
trisomiques et qui les aiment et qui
s'en occupe c'est aussi pour ça que
voilà c'est une des incidents réagissent
parce que voilà alors décision par a
posé problème exactement le fait de le
mettre en scène comme ça à la manière
d'une télé réalité en se filmant soi
même en mettant des petites musiques
émotions qui vont bien je trouvais la
croatie tous les gens que j'ai croisés
convenues qu'ont eu ça dans leur vie ils
sont meurtris ils veulent pas en parler
et parfois même ils veulent même pas
refaire d'enfants à cause de ça c'est un
gros traumatisme je pense qu'il doit y
avoir une pudeur guillaume le dis il ya
des faits l'armée veut dire qu'elle a
fait quand même des buffets trouve ça
déplacé je trouve ça je trouve ça pas
bien je trouve ça peuple s'il n'y a pas
de pudeur ya rien c'est d'amener la
petite musique derrière le scénario
guillot midi tous les gens qui sont
passés par là je pense moi j'en connais
aucun corps était capable de faire ça
deux films et aucun c'est un moment où
tu pleures c'est un moment où tu restes
avec ton homme vous êtes en train de
vivre un drame d'une vie et elle est en
train d on devient semaine 18 semaines
me demande pas aux gens d'être capable
de le faire on demande où elle a été
capable de le faire donc pourquoi pas si
ça aide les gens et ça va lui faire
savoir ce que m'avait
fait venir sur un sujet qui te peine ou
une des maladies par mcg pas les images
est pas une musique derrière j'ai changé
d'avis ou si ça peut aider parce qu'ils
ne connaissent pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]